and let's talk about sobriety yeah cuz
you've you've struggled with addiction
right I'll be sober sober for it'll be
30 years
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
no that's hard though like an addiction
is for a many different it's it's
whether it's food alcohol sugar shed
rugs bad relate whatever it is it's like
you get you kind of get it together in
one and and and it becomes a full-time
job but it changed my life it was the
best thing I ever did
enabled me to have a solid marriage and
kids and a career and I didn't end up a
crazy actor yeah always a possibility
which is always a possibility what was
the final because I have people in my
life that struggle with addiction are
currently going through it like what's
your advice for people like that cuz
it's just just an everyday struggle it
seems like well the real break the
habitual cycle I mean the one piece of
advice I really like to share having
raised two young men and you everybody
has to learn their relationship with
alcohol drugs
everybody has to they have to figure out
how they're gonna navigate it and having
just done that with two boys I like to
tell parents that aren't honestly all
you can do is try to keep them alive and
it's that bad and that yes you know one
can get sober for their jobs for their
wife for their kids they can't do it for
any of that they could only do it when
they decide they're done yeah truthfully
I mean it's it's kind of radical to
think about you know a man and you and
you think well I love them so much why
can't they do it for me or they're gonna
lose their job don't they understand it
until that light goes on there's
honestly not much you can do
that's it is when the light goes on
there is hope when the light goes on
absolutely yeah there's definitely a
great life beyond it for sure thank you
so much for being so open about it
because seriously not everybody is and
we all struggle with stuff and it's and
I think that people that do go through
inference of mine they go through it
it's nice to know you're not alone yes
the best part it's knowing you're not
like on some island like screwing up
your life and we're all on an island
screen apart
100 times more my big worry when I got
sober was I was gonna have fun anymore
like I was I was young that was 26 and I
was like I'm not giving up my fun and I
could never imagine what Wilson want to
get married I'm not gonna have a drink
so when I have a kid I'm not gonna have
a whiskey guess what
yes I didn't have any of that and it's
awesome I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this